[Musique]
toute ma vie je me suis demandé comment
étaient les membres de ma famille
voilées elle a accouché de six bébés le
même jour
on est des sextuplés
les pins possible que l'ado est pris non
d'idriss et pas plus ou moins on
n'allait même pas mettre sa ion tu es
mon frère resale alain fréhaut jeu très
gênant ça va voilà tu as connu mal
inconnu
bonne nouvelle ils décident
d'accompagner dans ce périple pour
retrouver nos frères ici c'est pour eux
c'est quoi ce bordel terre poil je ne
mords magnificient tu en mets pas tes
fans tout de suite la coupe air thé quoi
une stricte is magic voilà explique-t-il
aux est danseuse érotique c'est deux
choses différentes
fais gaffe à ce que tu dis plier relevé
que sur les visages s'te plaît arrête tu
sens que tu nous as tu eu son lot ces
deux républiques
je soutiens dernier mec tu le sais très
bien tu fais tes courses en magasin bio
[Applaudissements]
quand un peu joueuse à la pointe d'une
vie en rose wade attentats je rêve là
qu'est ce que c'est que ces pantins même
si beaucoup mon frère
bb pitt est à l'hôpital en soin intensif
ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'un membre
de la famille perdue de vue refait
surface pour donner son lait attendez
quoi pourquoi il faudrait montbrun de tu
veux pas prendre un des leurs et
comptent pas sur moi j'ai sniffé
beaucoup trop de shit dépoussiérant pour
andy et j'ai pris un petit parrain pas
plus tard qu'il neige en veut encore
[Musique]
il me reste plus qu'à trouver lisses
essonne
j'avais toujours rêvé de faire ça ces
derniers jours avec toi ou tu es le
meilleur tu y es tu sais depuis qu'on a
pu la route ou les deux j'ai fait des
choses que j'avais vu qu'elle a tenus
[Musique]
bataille de polochons
c'est comme ça qu'on fait une bataille
de polochons
[Musique]